everything at this stage that we know
about integration we're basing it off
what we know from differentiation we
will get to the point I promise
well we actually learned stuff about
integration that's peculiar to
integration and seems to have not much
to do at least directly to what we have
already established but for now we're
still in this establishing phase so we
know how to differentiate a bunch of
geometric functions actually we know how
to differentiate all of them we're gonna
learn how to integrate most of them as
you see so let's start the simplest of
the trigonometric functions is the base
one it's signed right because cos is
actually cosine it's based on sine so
what we know about the derivative of
sine is it is cuz it's very good so from
this knowledge we can make a statement
about integration that borrowers from
this right what we do is we're going in
the opposite direction
so therefore the integral of cos would
be signed do you agree with that with
one minor difference because we're
integrating the thing that comes along
is the constant of integration so let's
add C right there okay now the next one
after that is the one we just had a look
at right so the derivative of cos so
it's sneaky right because there's our
negative out the front as we just
establish so this is minus sine X so
when I go to integrate this is really
really sneaky right
if I were integrating just regular sine
X that's not the derivative that we
ended up with right so cyant integrate
into cos it differentiates into cos so
I'm going to before we write down the
answer I'm gonna put an intermediate
line here right we've seen this with one
we've got you know weed coefficients and
things like that at the front here the
coefficient I'm interested in is not a
fraction or anything like that it's just
negative one right there's a negative
one I want to be there that's not there
okay so what I'll do is I'll put one at
the front and it kind of counteracts
one I'm going to put on the inside you
okay with that this negative at the
front and this negative inside the
integral kind of cancel out to give us
the integral sine X so now from here we
can say firstly that minus sign just
hangs out the front nothing happens to
it
what is the function that differentiates
into negative sign it's cause right now
remember we made this comparison between
you know integrating is a bit like
learning to write upside down because
you know how to write your name but then
suddenly everything's backwards with
trig functions let's integrate those I
like learning to write upside down in a
mirror because you've got all these
extra negatives flying around and you
just have to be very very cautious I'm
it's hard enough doing these because we
confuse them all the time but now we've
got all the reverse versions of them so
you have to be very very cautious okay
we've got sign
we got cat cause what's next ten thank
you so the derivative of tan X so if you
just did this on the previous one so
this is SEC squared X we can make a
statement about integration by saying
well the integral of that what you ended
up with SEC squared X the integral of
that with respect to X should be equal
to it should take us back right to ten
thank you
good job Strang plus of course our
constant now as a notable absence on
this list right we now know how to
integrate sine just like when you have a
differentiate it we know into how to
integrate cos just like we knew how
differentiate it at this point in time
we know how to differentiate tan but I'm
just going to leave for now we will
return to this the integral of ten what
is that it doesn't appear here on the
right hand side yeah do you see that
okay so I don't have at least not on
this board the derivative that directly
tells me the answer to this result okay
we will return to it shortly but just
sort of make a note for yourself we
haven't been
the list just yet all right now the only
thing mrs. leach were you going to add
something the only thing I'm going to
add to this before we actually get
started on having to go with these is
that all of these are kind of like the
vanilla version of the trig functions
none of them involve any chain rule
right
so for example under this integrals
section over here
actually no we'll stay over here if we
are differentiate let's do let's go wrap
it to the top of list if I gave you sine
of 3x to do chain rule on this right I'm
gonna deal with the inside than the
outside so inside do a video for B just
the derivative the inside the inside
inside functions 3x so it's just 3 okay
insides dealt with now I'll do the
outside as you guys said that's cos and
don't forget the 3x is still 3 X so
there I'm good to go okay now when we
write some equivalent integral statement
with this right this integral if I
started with cos 3x hmm I know I'm gonna
end up with something like negative sine
3x right you see that all right no just
ready together through the sine 3x but
watch out for this inside derivative
just like with these guys over here
they're quite sneaky right here I
multiplied by 3 so what should I do here
to compensate for that I should divide
and then of course there's my plus C and
again just like we've been doing over
and over again if you are unsure in
stage you just look at it and you
differentiate it just like this stuff
you've been learning to write in a
mirror put it to a mirror and see if you
got it right or if you got it wrong we
can generalize this couldn't wait if we
had the derivative of sine of any
coefficient at the front right what
would that equal
a cause ax very good and so you could
say well there's an equivalent
equivalent integral statement of that
cause of any multiple of X with respect
to X it's not multiplication like you
told me its division right so that's 1
over a that's me dividing by a sine KX
okay okay now it's been unfortunate I
actually have one last one but I've run
out of space on my board so hopefully
you have space on your page actually no
I don't even need to do that I don't
need the space I'm going to pull on this
if you bring this back do you have your
reference sheet there if you don't have
your reference sheet can you get it
please all right so actually I shouldn't
zoom back out so you know where I'm
looking so this this is your reference
sheet right page 1 then page 2 then page
3 and you his calculus land now we know
a lot of this in fact we pretty much we
know almost everything on the left hand
side there's some stuff down the bottom
that's irrelevant to our course but on
the right hand side over here this is as
you can see integral calculus so this is
the land we're living in at the moment I
want you to look carefully at just this
second one down just have a look at this
one for me ok now what's going on here
hmm
when we integrate so you've already got
on your page right it goes to negative
cause can you just confirm that's what
you've got on your page right you
integrate sine it goes to negative cos
but then what's all of this f of X
business going on okay this is reverse
chain rule but with trig this is reverse
channel but it's with cheer trick if we
took this guy and we differentiate them
right this negative cos would turn into
sine thumbs up we know that but then
what happens with this f of X when you
do chain rule on it
this is this is the inside function here
do you agree is the inside function so
here comes the derivative of the inside
function and then the rest of it turns
into sine so if we were to do a concrete
example that'll leave that there
if we're going to do an example like
I'll give you a really simple one okay
two X minus one sine can you see this
now I know it looks messy okay
but I've written this exactly in that
form okay
look closely at this and this do you see
the relationship between the two of them
right in fact if you please write this
down if it helps you because it helped
me when I did this kind of question
right this is f of X this is the inside
function and so this guy hanging out the
front I know it looks messy but it's
just the derivative of x squared turns
into 2x minus X turns it 2-1 do you
agree
writing this F - and this F makes it
clear to you I hope that this is exactly
the situation we're looking at okay I'm
trying to put this into that form so I
can more readily recognize the answer so
use the reference sheet with me what's
the solution what's the integral - yeah
I'm just I'm reading off the reference
sheet this my right - cause yeah the
hold on wait it's f of X isn't it the f
of X which is this that's why I wrote
the f of X it's just like in question
rule you know how you're like oh this is
you and this is me right I write you and
I write V so I know which is which this
is F and this is F - so this is cause of
F and you can confirm this for yourself
by taking this guy and differentiator